[Música]
inicio el proceso de extradición del
expresidente peruano Alejandro Toledo
está previsto que el ex mandatario
llegue este domingo a Lima donde es
requerido por supuestamente haber
recibido sobornos por unos 35 millones
de dólares de la constructora brasileña
de ampliamos desde la capital peruana
desde Portugal el presidente de Brasil
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva volvió a
defender la propuesta de crear un grupo
de países negociadores para lograr un
cese de hostilidades en Ucrania el
mandatario continúa con su gira que
También incluye España y busca devolver
a Brasil al escenario internacional
[Música]
cada 22 de abril se conmemora el Día
Internacional de la tierra una jornada
en la que Naciones Unidas y otros
organismos llaman aumentar las acciones
para reducir el impacto humano en
nuestro planeta cada vez son más los
fenómenos climáticos extremos que
muestran la necesidad de actuar de
inmediato tenemos análisis
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Estados Unidos donde comenzó el proceso
de extradición del expresidente peruano
Alejandro Toledo el ex jefe de estado
voló desde San Francisco a Los Ángeles y
se prevé que llegue a territorio peruano
en la mañana del domingo la justicia
peruana lo reclama desde 2017 por su
presunta implicación en la trama de
corrupción de la constructora brasileña
odebrecht Francisco Zacarías
corresponsal de France 24 nos amplió la
información desde Lima
se inició el proceso de extradición del
expresidente Alejandro Toledo al Perú El
exmandatario fue trasladado en vuelo a
la tarde de este sábado desde el
terminal aéreo de San Francisco al
aeropuerto de Los Ángeles donde realizó
una parada de 4 horas antes de subirse
al avión que lo traerá a Lima vistiendo
una chaqueta verde jeans y zapatillas
Toledo tenía el rostro acongojado
mientras era conducido en una silla de
ruedas por un alguacil norteamericano
las autoridades peruanas han anunciado
que Alejandro Toledo llegará al país
andino este domingo a las 7:30 de la
mañana agente federales de los Estados
Unidos lo entregarán a la policía
peruana en el Aeropuerto Internacional
Jorge Chávez luego en la dirección de
policía aérea la jueza Margarita Salcedo
realizará el control de identidad y tras
ser examinado por médicos legistas
Toledo será trasladado en un helicóptero
hasta la prisión barbadío donde también
están encarcelados los expresidentes
Alberto fujimori y Pedro Castillo tras
mantenerse siete años fugitivo de la
justicia peruana Toledo cumplirá prisión
preventiva por 18 meses por un caso de
corrupción en el que la fiscalía lo
acusa Por presuntamente recibir sobornos
de 35 millones de dólares de la empresa
brasileña odebrecht a cambio de
concederle la construcción de una
carretera interoceánica con 77 años a
cuestas Alejandro Toledo podría ser
condenado a 20 años de prisión si es que
es declarado culpable por la justicia de
esta nación
continuamos con las declaraciones del
presidente brasileño Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva quien desde Portugal volvió a
abogar por crear un grupo de países
neutrales que sirvan como mediadores
para negociar el fin de la guerra en
Ucrania las palabras de querer encontrar
una tercera alternativa para resolver el
conflicto se produjeron tras la reunión
del mandatario brasileño con su homólogo
portugués Marcelo rebelo de Sousa la
primera en Europa desde que fue elegido
presidente en la comunicación conjunta
ambos condenaron la invasión la visita
hace parte de la gira que También
incluye a España y tiene como fin de
volver a Brasil al escenario
internacional luego del aislamiento
diplomático del gobierno de Jair
bolsonaro
yo nunca era tan ingenuo quiere
construir una forma No quiero complacer
a nadie solo quiero encontrar una manera
de traerlos a ambos a la mesa parecía
imposible pero sucedió en la Segunda
Guerra Mundial cuando parecía que no
iban a hablar y hablaron no tienes que
destruir el mundo para encontrar la paz
no tienes que destruirlo
esta guerra no debería haber comenzado
Rusia no debería haber invadido pero
invadió
decenas de chilenos se manifestaron en
Santiago para conmemorar el aniversario
número 50 de la primera marcha lgbt en
esa nación la movilización se produjo el
22 de abril de 1973 y marcó el comienzo
de la lucha por la igualdad de derechos
en esa época la marcha fue tan
controversial que las revistas y
periódicos usaron palabras peyorativas
en ese momento las principales demandas
del colectivo eran acabar con la
discriminación y la represión social
Además del derecho a contraer matrimonio
algo que se hizo realidad casi medio
siglo después en diciembre de 2021 pero
sólo hasta marzo de 2022 se implementó
este 22 de abril se conmemoró el Día
Internacional de la tierra una fecha que
busca crear conciencia sobre el
calentamiento global que cada vez genera
más efectos como las acidificación de
los océanos el calor Extremo los
incendios forestales y las inundaciones
previamente hablamos con Fernando Cortés
activista climático y cofundador del
movimiento de organizaciones
ambientalistas de Ecuador quien nos
habló sobre las principales amenazas
medioambientales que tienen en riesgo a
América Latina
en general América Latina tiene una
significación muy particular dentro de
la crisis ecológica y fundamentalmente
climática por sus niveles altos de
desigualdad sus altos niveles de
biodiversidad y también su rol dentro de
la economía Global en ese sentido
podemos interpretar de acuerdo a
diversos informes científicos
fundamentalmente
cinco grandes amenazas ambientales la
primera es la que tiene que ver con la
deforestación los incendios forestales y
la producción agrícola que afectan a los
bosques la salud humana la agricultura y
la biodiversidad por otro lado tenemos
la quema de combustibles fósiles que
genera una contaminación del aire que ha
llegado a representar cuatro punto cinco
millones de muertes anuales en todo el
año por último tenemos un consumo
totalmente responsable e inconsciente
que contribuye de Gran manera al cambio
climático ya que según un estudio de la
ONU el consumo en las ciudades causas
del 70% de todas las emisiones globales
Así mismo el consumo de plásticos llega
a invadir ciudades además de contaminar
mares Ríos manglares principalmente Y
por último tenemos un transporte y una
movilidad como uno de los principales
generadores de emisiones de carbono que
repercuten en el ambiente y en la salud
de las personas
se reanudó el rodaje de la cinta rust en
el estado estadounidense de Montana El
filme se vio ensombrecido tras la muerte
de la directora de fotografía halinas
que murió en el set de Santa Fe en Nuevo
México por un disparo del actor Álex
Baldwin con un arma de utilería el 21 de
octubre de 2021 Hace algunos días la
fiscalía de Nuevo México retiró los
cargos contra el actor por homicidio
Bolivia podría estar al borde de una
crisis financiera en medio de una
continua escasez de dólares el país fue
considerado como un milagro económico al
inicio de este siglo Por sus grandes
ganancias debido a la exportación de gas
natural y como un ejemplo de equilibrio
fiscal pero el modelo que ha llevado
Durante los últimos años ha que es su
éxito se desvanezca Andrés triviño nos
amplía
en Bolivia las filas por lograr hacerse
con dólares siguen haciéndose largas el
gobierno de Luis Arce insiste en la
estabilidad de la economía pero no ha
logrado controlar la caída de reservas
internacionales en una crisis que inició
a principios de marzo y señalan a un
brote especulativo como responsable los
empresarios se ven seriamente afectados
por las recientes restricciones resulta
que ayer fue al banco como las dos me
atrevería a decir que los dos últimos
meses a sacar dinero poco a poco porque
eso es lo que podía obtener Y ayer ya me
dijeron que en unos días más eso se va a
cortar y que voy a tener que sacar
solamente en bolivianos
Y yo que soy una persona que importo
maquinaria porque ese es mi trabajo
estoy imposibilitada para pagar a mis
proveedores porque ellos reciben en
dólares no en bolivianos la situación
preocupa en 2014 El Banco Central
contaba con 15.000 millones de dólares
de reserva pero en febrero esta se
ubicaban en un mínimo histórico con
apenas 3500 millones gracias a las
exportaciones de gas natural Bolivia
tuvo un gran crecimiento económico
durante la década de los 2000 el
gobierno gastó gran parte de sus
ganancias inesperadas en otorgar
subsidios como para la compra de
combustibles por lo que algunos culpan
la situación en una acumulación de
déficit Fiscales el modelo económico al
Que tanto se aferra el gobierno
está en una situación de crisis terminal
extraña que el gobierno tenga una
actitud de tanta negación y además de
inmovilismo Y eso se explica yo creo por
un bloqueo ideológico
este 21 de abril la cámara baja del
Congreso aprobó un proyecto de ley que
permitiría al Banco Central vender sus
reservas de oro para aumentar las de
moneda verde
cerramos con los triunfadores de la
décima edición de los premios platino
Argentina 1985 fue la gran triunfadora
de la noche la cinta de Santiago mitre
llegaba como favorita y consiguió cinco
premios entre ellos mejor película mejor
guión y mejor actor para Ricardo darín
al tiempo que la serie colombiana
noticia de un secuestro basada en el
libro del Nobel de literatura Gabriel
García Márquez se llevó cuatro
galardones
es todo por el momento en France 24
gracias por su sintonía
[Música]